these days entrylevel gpus launch for
nearly the price of consoles partly
because cheaper consoles are available
but also because gpus are more expensive
nvidia's new GeForce RTX 3050 obviously
isn't going to change that but the hope
is that it's going to be good enough
I'll give it to you straight right now
while you still have the chance this
card is not bad if you need a GPU today
and you don't mind 1080P and we'll have
the link below when they're available
stick around though and I'll tell you
why if you have a card now you might
might not want to be so Hasty thanks to
crucial for sponsoring this video step
up your game with crucial's P5 plus nvme
SSD it can be installed on the PC and
you can even easily upgrade your new
PlayStation 5 with up to 2 terabytes of
additional storage that also comes with
a 5-year warranty get yours today using
the link down
below the RTX 3050 is not a surprise on
paper you've got RT in tensor cores
you've got a little more than 2/3 the
Cuda cores of the RTX 3060 8 gigs of
memory on a 128bit bus and you've got
the anank encoder engine and more than
two display outputs to boot compared to
the Radeon RX 6500 XT amd's mobile GPU
cosplaying as a desktop card the extra
$50 doesn't seem like a big price to pay
for all of those benefits how much would
you pay for a dedicated video en coding
accelerator if your GPU didn't have one
or extra display outs now that glowing
endorsement for industry standard
features aside we do have to test
whether this is truly worth the extra
spend and thankfully our test bench is
still warm from our RX 6500 XT testing
we'll be throwing that GPU in along with
some Choice selections from both teams
to see if more memory and an encoder is
all the RTX 3050 brings to the table in
F1 2021 at least so far so good it not
only does it beat the RX 6500 XT but it
also comes pretty close to matching the
GTX 1660ti a GPU that launched for $30
more and lacks rate tracing capabilities
speaking of the rate tracing performance
ain't bad either easily pulling double
the frames the 6500 XT can drip out and
coming surprisingly close to the RX 6600
in the tier above at the same settings
Forza Horizon 4 brings more good news
even pulling a win over the 1660 TI
although amd's Contender isn't far off
here suggesting that this title isn't
sensitive to memory bandwidth not at
these settings anyway and AMD really did
drop the ball with the RX 6500 xt's
four-lane PCI Express connection and
64-bit memory configuration Far Cry 6
without rate tracing displays similar
results with the RX 6500 xt's
performance close but not quite matching
the RTX 3050 while getting absolutely
creamed the instant we turn on ra racing
thanks to both the gpu's extra video
memory and the difference in
optimization of nvidia's RT cores versus
amd's Ray accelerators Hitman 3 didn't
stutter for the RTX 3050 either and
we've once again got the highest results
out of other cards in class including
the
1660ti although it's worth pointing out
that if you're playing it stealthy
Hitman doesn't need Twitchy reaction
times what does is csgo and it's here we
see it fall behind the pack with the
cheaper at MSRP GTX 1660 super pulling
slightly ahead thanks to its wider
192-bit memory bus just like you can
pull ahead with a desk pad from LTD
store.com doesn't have be wider we've
got all sizes and a new configurator to
help you choose steepen got RGB if we
include the r tracing results the RTX 30
50 works out to be roughly 92% faster
than the RX 6500 XT but as we've said
rate tracing isn't something you'll want
to enable on this class of gpus without
upscaling algorithms like nvidia's dlss
which this card does support if we look
Instead at the non-r trace performance
it works out to be uh just about 23%
lead which is in near lock step with the
difference in price between the two
cards it's almost like they planned it
this way huh the performance is pretty
much spot-on with the GTX 1660ti too and
since it was a point of contention with
the 6500 XT here's how the 3050 does on
gen 3 it maintains within about 10% of
normal performance on benchmarks that
dripped up the 6500 XT most last time
around which isn't too surprising since
it's got those extra four lanes of PCI
Express bandwidth to work with
productivity is a little more cut and
dry the RTX 350's ability to use RT
cores for rendering and its inclusion of
a media engine easily puts it at Double
the performance of the 6500 XT and 33%
more than the 1660ti while productivity
needs vary from person to person this
puts the overall average score at a 66%
performance advantage over the 6500 XT
if we exclude rate race gaming if you
want to make it the fairest possible
comparison and exclude blender it works
out to roughly 30% I mean any way you
look at it it wins a win as with the
6500 XT first party Founders Edition
style cards don't exist so thermals will
vary from board to board our EVGA XC
card hit a peak of 74° which puts it at
a little under the RX 6500 xt's Peak
though it's so wash on average the
cooler is actually a little underbuilt
compared to our same cooler on the RTX
3060 XC so keep that in mind as we move
on to the power graphs it's here that we
see the radon 6500 XT is significantly
more efficient than nvidia's new card
although the RTX 3050 impressively draws
less power than the GTX 1660 super and
not by a little bit either and while you
might have a tough time finding it in
the core clocks graph the line and
therefore the clock stability is at as
smooth as any other in the lineup here
which shouldn't be too surprising
considering the thermal results this
card seems to have a bit of Headroom to
play with if you wanted to push the
power Target but your mileage will of
course vary depending on the card now
the problem many of you may have is yeah
that's great and all but this is
supposed to be a 50 Series card and it's
priced between the GTX 1660 super and TI
that's where it gets murky there are
many reasons why graphics cards are
getting more expensive these days and
and the unfortunate reality is it's
possible that AMD really did scrape the
barrel on the RX 6500 XT to hit that
$200 price point if so we've now seen
the compromises that have to be made to
hit that price point that we once
considered affordable and there really
is no going back that leaves me with
conflicting opinions about the RTX 3050
on one hand it delivers performance-wise
and is exactly what we expected a
further cut down ampere GPU and for the
first time in a 50 Series card we're
getting RT and tensor cores it's the RTX
2050 that we never got with no major
drawbacks and because it's a down Bend
GA 106 the same GPU that's in the RTX
3060 these are probably reject chips
that have been sitting idle this whole
time it'll add some Supply relief at
least until they sell through on the
other hand it's the RTX 2050 we never
got and they're calling it RTX 3050 with
a 60 series price tag this RTX tag X
began with the first RTX cards in 2018
and that was well before the current
scale apocalypse I just I worry that
there's no incentive to reverse this
trend even if manufacturing costs were
returned to normal like say GPU mining
ended today the reality is that both
Supply constraints stretching until 2024
by some estimates and the sheer pent up
demand from Gamers and Professionals for
high performance gpus is just going to
keep prices high it's not just one thing
a lot of people will'll probably try to
get an RTX 3050 at MSRP for new builds
and if they do I think they'll be happy
with them but the keyw there is try
Intel can't enter the game soon enough
and neither can amd's expected desktop
rdna 2 apus get subscribed by the way
because we are totally going to be
reviewing both of those things and both
are going to be disruptive in their own
ways in the meantime maybe it's time to
lean on one of PC Gaming's greatest
strengths and embrace its unparalleled
back catalog thanks to mine for
sponsoring this video mine is the Smart
data assistant that helps you discover
where your data is and helps you keep it
where you want it with mine you can
exercise your data rights and reclaim
your right to be forgotten by asking
services that you no longer use to
delete your information with how many
data breaches there are these days I
don't know about you guys but I don't
want any companies that I'm not using
holding on to any of my data if you sign
up mine will let you know how many
companies are holding your information
we ran our email and almost 250
companies are holding our data including
many services holding our financial data
that our team hadn't used in years mine
helps send an official data dele request
through your inbox so the company can
delete the personal data they have
stored mine also helps companies with
the ultimate goal of simplifying and
improving consumer online privacy
experience so sign up at cine.com using
the link down below and own your data
thanks for watching guys this got a
little depressing at the end there so
why not check out our video on splitting
a GPU between multiple virtual machines
maches it might just be the answer for
gaming couples and Families